merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rachid est mal je vous remercie
d'avoir rappelé le bilan rappeler aussi
et je crois que nous ne le faisons pas
suffisamment les séquelles importantes
avec lesquels ressortent nos concitoyens
qui sont hospitalisés en raison de cette
maladie de la copie de 19 et dont nous
avons assez peu de recul aujourd'hui
pour savoir combien de temps ils les
garderont et vous avez raison dans ce
contexte là les progrès consacré par la
recherche les nouvelles qui sont
apportées sont des lueurs d'espoir il
faut le dire parce qu'elles sont parfois
rare dans cette épidémie
et vous avez raison de poser la question
de la préparation de notre pays comme
dans l'ensemble des pays dans le monde à
l'arrivée d'un vaccin qui permettra de
vacciner la population sur ce point nous
avons déjà avancé
nous avançons avec prudence parce que
nous en sommes encore aux essais de
phase 3 avec des résultats préliminaires
les résultats préliminaires dont nos
agences de santé qu'elle soit européenne
ou française ne dispose pas de
l'intégralité des détails il faut donc
être prudent oui à la lueur d'espoir non
à vendre du rêve entre guillemets pour
un court terme qui
pourraient ne pas se concrétiser mais
d'abord nous avons préservé des doses de
vaccins au niveau européen plusieurs
centaines de millions de doses pré
réserver pour cinq laboratoires et un
sixième contrat est en cours de
finalisation je crois que ça fait autour
de 90 millions de doses réservé
pré-réserver déjà pour notre pays
ensuite nous avons mis de côté entre
guillemets une somme budgétaire pour
2021 pour payer une première partie de
vaccin 1 milliard 500 millions d'euros
dans le plfss pour 2021 que vous avez
examiné ensuite il ya un travail
logistique pour garantir que le vaccin
puisse être acheminée jusqu'à nos
concitoyens ce travail est en cours il
s'agit d'identifier des centres des
transporteurs des conditions de traces
de transport sachant que les différents
vaccins ne nécessite pas les mêmes
conditions de stockage et de transport
mais nous travaillons sur plusieurs
scénarios enfin il ya la question
importante que vous avez posé sur les
publics cibles est prioritaire sur ce
point nous avons saisi la haute autorité
de santé et le comité consultatif
national d'éthique qui nous rendront
leurs conclusions dans les prochains
jours et c'était la lumière de ce
travail que nous serons en mesure de
communiquer des informations sur ce
point
[Musique]